pyaara Boyd came home from Dubai to
design the sculpture made from
recyclable materials it's his way of
crediting Lebanon's women for being at
the forefront of the so-called October
Revolution this artwork stands in
Beirut's martyrs square which has been
taken over by opponents of the governing
elite who have been demanding change the
corruption that is in this country want
us to be violent they are dragging us to
be violent but then the woman comes here
and say cool down guys I'm gonna deal
with those people we are nice women have
been on the front lines visiting
strongholds of the mainly sectarian
political parties reaching out to their
supporters who have attacked peaceful
protesters they say they are trying to
keep the country United and avoid a
return to the days of the Civil War
there have been violent incidents but
the protest movement has remained
largely peaceful but there is also fear
of a financial collapse banks are
imposing controls on access to cash
there's a shortage of dollars which
resulted in the national currency the
lira losing nearly forty percent of its
value on the black market a political
crisis is preventing the formation of a
government that is needed to implement
economic reforms and those changes are
required for international assistance to
start flowing in what we all have is one
main goal and that is an independent
government from all the political
parties as long as we all stay together
and that's what we're just trying to
keep a strong front on the ground with
the same demands and they'll just
they're gonna be forced to listen sooner
or later so far the governing alliance
is refusing to give a political power
despite almost two months of protests
instead they have tried to intimidate
those in the streets thugs were
literally out on the streets smashing
property terrorizing coming down to the
proto-tool the protest sides pulling
down tents and yet people's response was
we're not going to
this is the this is we're not going to
respond to this we're not going to
become sectarian protesters used what
was left of the burned tents to build
this statue the Phoenix a symbol of
renewal and resistance the message that
they will continue the struggle that
began on October the 17th
XANA father al Jazeera Beirut